close your eyes and imagine an iPhone
it's pretty easy to do right thin really
well-made it's a rectangle it's mostly
just a screen and a home button now take
that take away the headphone jack
make the home button not a button
congratulations you just designed the
iPhone 7 ok so it's not quite that
simple while these new phones the iPhone
7 the iPhone 7 plus do just seem like
faster brighter more splash proof
versions of the phones that came before
there are some pretty big upgrades here
first let's talk about design there are
two new colors to the iPhone 7
well blacks not really a color but go
with me here it's this one piano black
which is called jet black or this one
which is matte and is just called black
me I like the matte black better and
this one just picks up a lot of
fingerprints but either way it's up to
you the home buttons changed too in that
it's not a button anymore instead of
uses haptic feedback to buzz and tap
when you press on it gives feedback but
it just feels weird like I'm about to
put my thumb through the glass of my
phone I'm getting used to it but I don't
love it which gloves and one nice
consequence of that is that the iPhone 7
is water-resistant it can't go scuba
diving but it can go in the pool or in
the shower without any problems at all
which is awesome ok it's time to bring
up the touchy subject there is no
headphone jack on the iPhone 7 Apple
dumped it it's gone dead goodbye
sayonara Apple does bundle lightening
headphones with every new iPhone 7 but
it really thinks the future is Wireless
more specifically it thinks the future
is 159 dollar
air pod wireless headphones the air pods
sound fine not great and they make you
look a little like a confused alien from
the future but the way they connect and
pair with your phone is amazing if you
use lots of Apple devices they work so
seamlessly with them all and they're
really great for interacting with Siri
what's on my calendar for today
really the biggest change to the iPhone
itself not to mention the biggest reason
to upgrade is the iPhone sevens camera
booth models got a big upgrade to the 12
megapixel camera which now takes
brighter faster richer photos especially
in low-light this is a really great
smartphone camera the seven plus is even
better it uses two cameras one wide and
one zoomed in to give you real actual
optical zoom with one tap of a button in
the camera app and since both sensors
are collecting data every time you take
a photo
it makes photos even better and there's
more to come to a software update is
coming this fall that's gonna bring that
soft background bokeh feel that pros
love and Apple is releasing AP eyes that
are gonna let developers do crazy things
with your photos that's true across iOS
10 to your iPhone isn't really about the
hardware anymore it's about all the
things it can do developers now have
access to apps and messages and maps and
more across all of iOS and even the air
pods which can sense when you take them
out of your ears and automatically pause
your music could turn into super smart
buds with the help of Siri access don't
forget next year is the iPhones 10th
anniversary and Apple loves to do big
things for big anniversaries there might
be a lot more coming but until then
close your eyes imagine the iPhone and
make it a little better a little faster
a little harder to break a little more
glossy like a grand piano nothing too
crazy just better that's the iPhone 7